we start with some breaking news in the
last few minutes from the supreme court
and that is the long-awaited judgment
in the test case dispute over claims of
business interruption insurance due to
the pandemic
and the court has uh handed a win to the
financial conduct
authority and small businesses against
insurers the supreme court upheld
appeals
by the fca and dismissed appeals by the
insurers this landmark win for
small firms against six of the world's
largest insurance companies
well joining me now to talk about this
is mark killick he's from the steering
committee of the victorious claimants to
his cox action group
and richard leedham he is the head of
commercial litigation
at mishkan torreira the law firm which
has represented them in this case
gentlemen welcome to you both richard
let me start with you if i may please i
mean this is a
horrendously complex case here can you
just explain
what the supreme court has said yeah
actually in um it's not that complex um
what the supreme court has said is that
in insurance policies
that cover business interruption where
the loss
is not tied to property damage
then if a business has suffered
interruption because of the government
actions due to that business should be
covered for its losses
one of the main points of law here was
around the
the sort of vicinity in which uh a
business had suffered a lockdown or a
closure wasn't it
correct and and on that the the supreme
court has been clear to say
that there has to be an occurrence of
covered within vicinity but it goes on
to say that in terms of what has caused
the loss
that each of those um cases of coded
throughout the country
are all equally effective causes of the
government
mandated lockdown back in march and so
so long as there is one case of covid
within the relevant vicinity
there is cover well uh mark let me bring
you in uh you must be highly delighted
you got the champagne
cracking open yet it it's an
extraordinary outcome ian i mean
the supreme court upheld all the policy
holders
uh uh grounds for appeal they upheld
none
of the of of the insurers uh uh
appeal grounds it's great news for the
30 000 uh policy holders at his cox his
cox
have been utterly humiliated i think
they led the insurers
and they led the insurance in the wrong
direction the fca
say 370 000 uh policyholders
across the uk could benefit from this
and given how many businesses are
literally flattened their backs
desperate for this money finally for the
supreme court to come and be so clear
as to what should be done is is just a
great result i mean it is an absolute
landmark judgment
mark presumably though this is tinged
with sadness on the basis that a lot of
the companies that were waiting for uh
payouts from their insurers are no
longer around to uh
benefit from them and you're so right
i mean in our own group the the his cops
action group uh we have 400 members
uh at least five or six of them have
already gone under and many others are
actually
teetering on the brink the key thing
here ian
is that the insurers now start to pay
out and of course there's still a
concern
that even given the supreme court
judgment they won't do that when you
like to believe they're now going to
start
doing the right thing and paying out on
their policies but
i'm not entirely convinced that that's
going to happen why do you say that
well i don't know what you know you'd
like to think for the best but there are
you know you wonder whether the insurers
will actually embrace this where they
will say that this is clear and
unambiguous
or whether they start nickel and diming
on every single point
you know what what britain's businesses
want is that the policies that they
bought
are honored mark we've spoken to you on
a number of occasions about this case
just to remind
uh people who who may not be familiar
with your story what how you were
affected by all this
well you know i i i i work for a pr
company media media zoo
we were impacted as many many other
businesses were by uh
by kobe we checked our insurance it was
crystal clear
that it triggered we are we we are we
applied to have our
our losses mitigated by the insurers
like many many other businesses across
the uk
and we're astonished to find that his
scots has turned us down flat
his cox said in april that their
policies do not apply to pandemics they
said it in terms as a market statement
nine months later the supreme court is
saying that's
absolute nonsense what were they
thinking
richard marx just raised the possibility
of in his words the insurance companies
now nickel and diming
every single claim would small
businesses have legal recourse if the
insurers started to do that
um yes they do they've got one major
tool in their armoury now that perhaps
wasn't there before
in that whilst it's true that each claim
has to be adjusted it's
of course not right that an insured says
well i've lost
a hundred thousand pounds mr insurer
please pay up the claim has to go
through a quantum process
but that has been going on in the
background on a lot of the claims
in any event so that that's mark's point
is that that should not
now be held up and the court has also
clarified that
um any any sort of downturn in the
business
before the claim was triggered due to
covid should be ignored in any
calculation of that so you just look at
what the business was doing last year
what it's done this year
the calculation should be simple but but
the other tool in the armory
point that the insureds have and it's i
think
implicit in the in the judgment is that
this should never have happened the the
court has said it's really clear
what should have happened and the
insurer's position was that effectively
cover was illusory
and they made that point to the insureds
just at the time
when the insureds needed insurers to
step in
as a result of that we think there's a
good case for most insureds to have a
claim
for damages for late payment of of their
insurance money on top of
their insurance claim and that's
something that lots of lawyers are going
to be looking at
and lots of those claims are going to be
put forward as well as claims
for the actual money that's due under
the policy
that's a really interesting point i mean
how much could those claims run into do
you think
that is a that is a good question
because this
um this route to recourse which came in
under the enterprise act and is
enshrined in the insurance act has never
to our knowledge been tested in court
before and
the damage will be assessed probably on
an individual basis
but it seems to us this is a paradigm
case of where
that remedy should be available to
insurers and it's simply not good enough
for the insurance market to say well
we had to go through this test case the
way the law works
is is is a judgment sets out what the
law has always been
these claims should have been paid and
agreed to be paid back in march
and although the supreme court judgment
is
is is it is to be applauded and the way
the fca
ran the case is to be applauded um it's
it's um absolutely apparent that it was
the appeal of the first instance
decision was driven by insurers
and that has delayed things by another
four months the first instance decision
came out
on the 15th of september and this
judgment is largely
an affirmation in an even more
comprehensive way it's true
of that judgment so another four months
has effectively been wasted well hang on
i mean when the fca and the insurers
agree to take this through the legal
process there was
an agreement written into this whichever
side lost in the first outcome there
would be a fast track appeals process
i mean if the small businesses had lost
first time round they would have taken
this to the supreme court wouldn't they
well that the appeal was envisaged
you're right that's a good point but
it's still
um it could have been avoided is my
point and when you're looking at the
overall
um time you're back to mark's examples
of businesses
that have failed in the period between
september and january
that could have been avoided
so it's all it's also worth saying that
the judgment is clear i mean first of
all it says
that if the insurers were right
the insurance they were offering was
illusory which is pretty damning
and more than that it says that the
insurer's position was clearly contrary
to the spirit
and the intent of the relevant
provisions
that is getting precious close to saying
the insurers have
tried to cheat do you have any sympathy
for the insurers i mean to go back to
your point about them so-called nickel
and diming claims i mean
they are going to want to send in the
loss of justice aren't they i mean we've
seen
for example from the furlough scheme
there's been an awful lot of fraud
that's gone on around this pandemic it's
not unreasonable for the insurers is it
to want to check that
people have lost exactly what they're
claiming
i don't think it is unreasonable but i
do think it's unreasonable of the
insurers to have dragged this out for
nine months
to have forced us to form a group
which eventually dragged the fca into
this
uh to fight and fight to get what we
paid for
it used to be that the insurance
industry said my word is my bond
whatever happened to that they've
trashed the reputation
of britain's insurers right across the
piece now you know
is cox has been humiliated by by
by this by this decision and i think all
worth
saying is it's time to pay up guys it's
time to do the right thing
mark do you think uh companies like you
in future will take out this sort of
business interruption cover
well i certainly won't take it out with
his [ __ ] here and that's for certain
[Laughter]
but uh to richard's point about the way
the fca has handled this
do you think do you agree with him that
the fca has uh actually done the right
thing
by by consumers here and and the
regulated
in this occasion the sca have done an
amazing job
there's no doubt both in the way that
they stepped in after
after we alerted i think the country to
what was going on here
they've driven it through the hizcox
action group
and and richard leader in michigan have
been right there alongside them and we
were intervenors right up the supreme
court of course
so we were alongside them but there's no
question the sa have done a fantastic
job
uh for small businesses across the uk
today